meda torre evacuation orders have been
issued for residents along the Brazos
River in Houston's southwestern suburbs
the Army Corps of Engineers overnight
released water from reservoirs that have
been overwhelmed by the storms they want
to prevent a catastrophic the levee
failure but the release along with
Harvey's continued downpours could cause
all kinds of new flooding Jamie yuccas
is in Sugar Land where people are trying
to escape their neighborhoods by boats
Jamie good morning good morning Maurice
now take a look it's still raining and
that is bad news for the people inside
this gated community because the waters
here rose about nine inches overnight it
now makes it impossible to leave this
neighborhood by car I'm told by
constable Trevor nails that yesterday
they were able to rescue about 50 people
but they did that by airboat get this
that airboat captain is now having to
evacuate his own family and will not be
able to get here today to help out in
the effort an 18-wheel tractor trailer
is supposed to be coming in here as well
but yesterday that posed a problem
especially to those who are elderly or
to have small children trying to hoist
them up into that truck so the only way
out I'm told right now is if people want
to leave their homes and try to walk
through these waters and what we know
about these waters is that they are
filled with alligators and snakes
because of a lake that has now
overflowed within this neighborhood so
some people may try to make their way
out but that's what they're gonna have
to contend with
there are several neighborhoods along
the Brazos River just like this one that
are going to have this problem
especially today trying to get out and
get this this area just had a hundred
year flood less than 18 months ago they
never expected to be in this position
again so soon gale boy none of those
options sound good you can leave and
walk but don't worry there's alligators
in the water that's tough Thank You
Jamie